[Musique]
notre guide nous entraîne dans les
entrailles de l'opéra cette forêt de
poutres a rempli son office depuis
l'origine du grand théâtre soit presque
un siècle et demi à soutenir les
représentations nous sommes ici sous la
scène neuf mètres de haut réparties sur
trois niveaux cet espace remplit une
fonction très précises il sert à
aménager des apparitions scéniques voilà
en volume ou des toiles ou des personnes
avec un apparition sociaux une trappe à
tampon ça se fait fréquemment des
escaliers partout nous nous rendons à
présent au cinquième étage dans ce qu'on
appelle les cintres ici en fait on
procès de levage des décors hauteur donc
ça s'appelle cendrier voilà est donc là
pour vous donner l'exemple
il m'a donné ne m'a demandé de lui
chargé c'est à dire de faire charger
c'est descendre un décor pour se pencher
nous est appuyé c'est leur montée en
fait pour le dissimuler derrière des
frises ça fait un peu penser au système
salut à tous les systèmes de
marin sur les bateaux il ya tous les
fils pour pourtant d'étendre les voiles
et sauf que là on est sur un système on
a tellement plus moderne qu'un bateau le
cintrier est en contact étroit avec la
régie lumière 18 mètres plus bas
pendant ce temps les solistes de l'homme
de la mancha prennent un moment pour se
concentrer dans les loges et la folie
suprême est elle pas de voir la vie
telle qu'elle est le grand théâtre de
tours ils en connaissent pour la plupart
les charmes
quelle est la taille humaine et à
chaleur humaine surtout pour ce genre
d'oeuvre je pense que c'est bien d'avoir
quelque chose de chaleureux une belle
salle comme celle ci c'est malgré tout
un très très joli théâtre mais très très
bien reçus c'est très important pour
nous parce qu'on est comme je dis d'e.on
et des itinérants on est des nomades et
c'est pour nous le théâtre la maison
ducasse cesser la maison c'est là où on
va passer la plupart du temps et donc on
a besoin de bien s'y sentir il reste
quelques jours avant les premières
représentations devant le public
alors pour l'instant les répétitions
c'est sans costumes et avec un piano
pour tout orchestre je suis sincèrement
navré d'avoir quelque peu perturbé votre
les mangas multi là aussi avec julien
d'ajustement en précision le spectacle
prend forme pour la prochaine étape
tous les artistes seront réunis sur la
scène et dans la fosse
[Musique]